social media is poisoning our brains
everyone knows that yet no one can
actually stop using these pieces of
technology we're addicted and even
though we know it we still cannot put
them down i recently had a conversation
with new york times best-selling author
robert greene you may have seen some of
his books like the 48 laws of power or
mastery in my conversation robert
explicitly states why social media is
poising our brains and how we have to
learn to think for ourselves here's
robert explaining this exact idea as you
kind of extrapolate that out obviously
the rise of social media and technology
uh there's many people uh would argue
that's been a net positive right a
company like a facebook or twitter
allows people to share ideas it allows
for people to learn it allows for
families to reconnect or old friends
and then you can kind of go off of the
social media platforms other pieces of
technology that have definitely had a
positive impact but it sounds like
you're making a nuanced argument which
is although there are very many positive
impacts of that technology one of the
downsides or maybe one of the steps
backward for society is that we spend
less time face to face with that human
interaction
is that okay because there's a positive
impact from the technology and and uh
you know not everything is 100
good uh or do you think that actually
society would be better off maybe
without some of the social media
platforms or uh kind of the activities
that people do on their phones every day
well imagine this imagine you didn't
have your access to all these things
that you have
and the human animal is made so that we
need constant uh stimulation our brains
are continually needing things to feed
on to to process
and so if you don't have your phone you
don't have your computer you're left on
your own what are you going to do you're
going to become extremely creative with
what with your time with how you you're
going to find ways to entertain yourself
often in a group situation
and i remember when i was a child
i'm not trying to sound like i'm i'm a
luddite or anything i'm just answering
your question as best i can
but the fact that you know i we had
television and of course that was a big
thing because i grew up i'm so old i
grew up in the 60s and the 70s but um
mostly you had to make up your own games
you had to constantly create things to
keep yourself from being continually
bored and that kind of develops the mind
it develops your imagination in a very
positive way
and i remember back in the early years
of the internet which you know
strangely enough was like some 20 years
ago where it had more of that that kind
of interactive possibilities than it
that have come since then so i remember
for instance
like on amazon something that was really
exciting to me
was i would look for a particular book
and then it would suggest other books
which it still does but it would also
suggest
communities of people that you could
interact with who also were fans of this
book or might be interested in this kind
of subject i thought this was great and
i was actually connecting to people i
even made some friends people who who
are like nietzsche fanatics like i am or
particular forms of philosophy etc
and soon amazon got rid of that because
the um the algorithms something like
that isn't making any money for amazon
and the need to continually generate
profit made it so that
everything was was designed for for
selling things and so
thank you and so um
uh
so you know peop that kind of
interpersonal thing where you could
create a community of like-minded people
and connect
is something that's been degraded over
the years and it's turned into into
something else in a way and
i think people are kind of hungry
for more real human interaction i'm
sensing this
in gen c in young people who are growing
up now that they're a little bit tired
weary of the hours that they're being
sucked into things like instagram which
you know i i use quite a bit i'm at
fault as well i i think i found it i'm
very seductive but i think they're
hungry for something a little more real
a little more experiential a little more
interactive and interpersonal
and i think actually that is the future
combining the immense powers
of the digital world which we all know
and appreciate and love
with something a little more personal
and human where you use this
immense tool
for something where you know okay we now
can create a group and we can get we can
meet people you know
but you know the thing that's
revolutionized my life
to highlight the positive aspect
is
just in if i have some idea like i'm
researching a story about a particular
man
who there are not many books written
about for my new book
and i can just go on google and put his
name in with like two other words of a
subject that he's interested in and all
these things pop up it's insane it's the
kind of thing that would like a leonardo
the da vinci would have like just gone
crazy over the powers of it are
absolutely immense but it could be used
i think sometimes for better purposes
that's my only point now if there's one
thing that we learned over the last two
and a half years it is that the
algorithm is incredibly powerful it
tries to program your brain it tries to
tell you what to think it shows you what
it thinks that you want to see but what
you need to do is take back control
fight back against the algorithm instead
learn to think for yourself think
critically think independently and start
actually looking at the source material
go find the data points go find the
information do the hard work do not get
programmed by a piece of software do not
allow large technology companies to tell
you what to think instead
think for yourself
it will serve you well both in the short
and the long term
robert green nails it social media is
poisoning your brain
and the algorithm is programming your
mind all you have to do is opt out at
some point
spend a little less time on social media
and in front of the algorithm and start
to think for yourself
you'll thank yourself later